test for you to determine your level and
after 10 years of doing very well on
French because he was a good student
passed every year got high marks in
French they classified him as a beginner
because of course the test was all based
on grammar and all of the grammar
instruction that kids get at school I
believe they're largely just able to
retain it until the next test and it has
relatively little long-term impact on
them so he was able to go to the teacher
at Yale and say a few words in French so
they moved him into second year so he
wasn't that beginner but after ten years
in our school system and all those
credential teachers and they all went to
you know seminars on how to teach better
and then at the end of that a very
bright student it gets classified his
beginner and I mentioned that we had
similar experience in New Brunswick
where 30 minutes a day 12 year 12 years
of language and no one can speak the
language when I have had the opportunity
to be with English Canadians where they
had to speak French these are English
Canadians who have studied French at
school for 10 years or however long they
don't speak grammatically correctly all
they're able to do is remember those few
words that somehow through whatever
exposure they had to the language have
stuck
so they will say la marche / s'il vous
play that s'what all I can say they
can't put together a proper sentence
because the only thing that sticks is
that the word is the words that they
acquired largely through their listening
in region so you know the idea that I as
a lay man then as a keen language
learner have not qualified to comment on
what to do in the classroom
I don't accept someone commented on one
of my videos that a lot of the things
that I say about language learning I say
those because I have a lot of experience
of language learning but someone and he
even said that someone had learned two
or three languages would probably do
what you do but someone who has never
learned a language needs to be guided
and I would agree with that but not
guided in terms of taught the rules of
the language he such a learner needs to
be guided in how to learn that's what
they should teach in the classroom
to learn if we go back to the basic
Trinity of language learning attitude
time on task and the ability to notice
the teacher has to focus first of all on
that attitude they have to get that
person somehow motivated to learn if and
and that is a difficult thing to do but
in response to my person in Japan I
think one important ingredient in the
classroom is enthusiasm enthusiasm about
the language enthusiasm about the
students about the subject matter
enthusiasm can be infectious I remember
we had a Latin teacher at school I used
to come in and he was very enthusiastic
he was also a football coach and he
would bring in his books and in those
days we had to stand up when the teacher
walked in the room and then we sat down
and his thing every day was he would
drop the books from about three feet
high
onto his desk and we had to sit down
before his books hit the desk
and stupid thing and woke us up and
another thing he had us doing is we had
competitions on who could decline in
Latin mounds the fastest so I can still
to this day I can go bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bleach please that's belém belém
belém belém valley below blah blah blah
blah Lauren please please that's all I
remember from Latin but doing something
that was fun and yet exposing me to the
words exposing me to something connected
with the language is positive so
enthusiasm making it fun I think that
the teacher should speak in the native
in in the language of instruction but I
think the students should be allowed to
answer in their own language the main
thing again is to get them involved with
the language don't give them hard
questions for example I've now you know
when I have this teach yourself this old
teacher self check book that I've had
for many years and I discovered then I
was going through it and of course I
always avoid the exercises because I
hate doing exercises and I think the
time that I spend thinking about the
language actually is a waste of time I'm
better off getting exposed time
I know this goes contrary to the idea
that you got to do things in order to
retain them but at least my brain
doesn't work that way but what I found
very effective was to read the answers
so if there is a question about the
dative case and all the answers are
gonna be in the dative case so I just
read ten answers so I get this
concentrated exposure to the dative case
then the next one is maybe you know the
genitive case or certain forms of the
verse so as long as there are it could
be numerals so they're testing on one
specific subject rather than putting me
through the problem of thinking about it
and getting it wrong I just go to the
answer read the answers it's a
concentrated dose of certain patterns
and the fact is that so much of the
beginner language content is so boring
anyway it doesn't really matter you
might just as well be reading and
listening to this concentrated dose of a
certain pattern as listening to some
silly story in my opinion so what I
would do in the classroom is yes
storytelling she suggests yes I would
help them basically try to get them
motivated and tell them where they can
go to find good content have them
understand that that the first goal is
comprehension right now the goal is to
pass a test to get some obscure grammar
point right for the test and then
subsequently forget the rule or there's
this hope that somehow we're going to
speak very early and I just don't
believe that and I think we would do far
better if we said look your goal is to
understand the language if you can get
to where you can understand the language
everything else will fall into place
over time and in order to understand the
language you have to do a lot of
listening and reading but find stuff
that interests you it I also don't
believe the crashing theory that you've
got to be reading stuff that's 95% known
words you would take forever to increase
your vocabulary you know I've been
working up check now and and most of my
stuff when I started with 50% unknown
words and you just have to have a
methodology but you have to expose
yourself to more words than that the 95
percent known words I don't think it's
realistic
so take the pressure off performing
don't force the kids to listen to other
kids in the class reading out loud and
saying things in the language
sure if they want to speak in the class
that's fine if they don't that's fine
too it's more important for the kids to
listen to the teacher who's speaking
with the right accent and so forth and
so on
so the classroom becomes a sort of a
motivation center a source of the
language from the teacher if the teacher
is a native speaker a guide on how to
learn you have to and this is difficult
but you have to persuade people who have
never learned another language and never
learned to speak another language well
you have to persuade them that this is
something that they can do and I think a
lot of first-time person is on their
first language they don't think they can
do it and they have all these other
faults they are convinced that they have
to nail everything down and whatever
they learned in the first chapter they
have to be able to produce it and stuff
and so you have to disabuse them of that
and say look don't worry about the
results in one week or one month worry
about the results in a year from now and
so focus entirely on passively allowing
your brain to acquire the language and
let's do things that are fun I mean I
think this is a getting back to my Latin
thing I think that's that's kind of fun
you can have competitions with words you
know if again if people were using
language I of course would recommend
then they could bring in their
vocabulary lists and you could have a
screen and you could flash up
multiple-choice questions or you could
flash up even flashcards and and have
teams of people competing and shouting
out the answer and anything that gets
them going and and has them somehow
interacting with the language is good
and things should be easy like we've
introduced a link now a multiple-choice
question which is dead easy because it's
usually quite obvious which one of the
four is correct but it's very effective
because it's easy so up pops a word a
new word in check with four choices I
picked the one that I know is right I
press the button what do you know I'm
right good for me and then there's a
text-to-speech icon there so I can even
listen to it and then do the next in the
next the next and it's very gratifying
you're getting the right um I might get
one in ten wrong but 910 I'm getting
right I feel great so there are little
things like that that we need them now
and like we have this dictation thing
we're using the text-to-speech and you
listen to Word and you have to write it
out and all of these thing
just different ways of interacting with
the words to that I find not too boring
not to Barney but most the time of
course you have to be listening and
reading but in the classroom you could
let people read but I think to get some
fun activities going around the language
in some way that that makes it seem fun
for them but at the same time making
them understand that that the success of
their language learning depends entirely
on them that you cannot teach the
language the teacher cannot teach it
they have to learn it through enough
exposure the teacher can help can answer
questions can point certain things out
but ultimately if they are not consuming
enough of the language on their own they
aren't gonna learn so it's a bit of a
ramble and I realized I'm well over my
ten minutes here but those are some
thoughts on the role of a teacher in a
language class thank you for listening
bye for now